jean michel maire de btan la barre
pendant tout son week-end voilà donc ça
ça vous étiez dans le train comme à lens
était en train pour choisir les gens
vous reconnaissez ah oui oui c'est fait
et pour être sûr que jean-michel
respecte bien bien sûr son gaz
on a envoyé une équipe le film et tout
le week-end regardez ce que ça a donné
jean michel maire en a pas a déjà lâché
[Musique]
super
attention voilà bien la page
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cyril je suis vanné ça fait passer un
week-end de pâques horrible enfin au
niveau est vraiment sympa quand même
bon j'ai pas j'ai pas trouvé deux mais
la carotte
j'avais laissé à paris mais je te
promets que si j'avais trouvé ben je
l'aurais mise en
[Applaudissements]